new tourism numbers showing more and
more people making vacation plans for
las vegas the strip is packed
that's right well tourists say the
vaccine is playing a role in their
decision
joe muller spoke with some people on the
strip today he is live to tell us
how safe they feel to travel joe
well the vaccine is becoming more
available and more people are getting it
we talked to people here on the strip
today they say they feel better
traveling and they feel better here i
feel a little bit safer having a
vaccination
as more vaccines get administered it
seems like more people are coming to
vegas
we've both been vaccinated one time got
my first round on wednesday
and it did me in but i'm ok now
vaccinated visitors feel better yeah
there's a little bit of relief to it
getting out and traveling those who
haven't feel fine too
i still felt comfortable coming
because i just feel like a lot of people
have had their vaccination from the
amount of airline passengers to room
occupancy the numbers show
more people are coming we just unveiled
february's visitation numbers
which shows a 20 percent increase in
visitation
lauren nelson craft from the las vegas
convention and visitors authority says
1.5 million people visited in february
up several hundred thousand from january
march especially
um we believe will be stronger than
february one
because vaccine distribution has
increased
and second march madness has been a big
driver
spring typically is bustling with
convention goers something nelson craft
says will return
soon the first major city-wide show will
be world of concrete that will be
returning in
early june we will have a couple smaller
shows leading up to that
visitors want to see the vegas they know
and love once again
we want to see you all come back to life
and start making money again
now back out here live room occupancy is
up more than 10 percent on the strip and
downtown the lbcva would like to see
midweek room occupancy improve something
they think
conventions will eventually help out
with reporting live here on the las
vegas strip joe mullen 8 news now